[Laughter]
i was i was like what
are you putting me up
now i can get out and enjoy some serious
guilt-free you're my young man
men have knobs
women have families
pop knob
in for me
[Laughter]
a man as a knob
a woman
you see men have knobs
women have families
pop knobbing funny
[Laughter]
oh god
you [__]
oh god you don't know how hard that is
steve well i was losing it here don't
hurt me
dad
i defy anyone
it in your hand and grip it lightly
like that
oh that's good
now first take a deep breath and blow
don't suck
and then put your fingers
oh god is it the fact that i've got one
leg show than either
i hadn't noticed yeah noticed
what are you doing
i'm just trying to not laugh take it in
your hand and grip it lightly
like that oh that's good
now first you take a deep breath and
blow
don't suck
and put your finger over the hand
morning
who are you well i'll be whoever you
want me to be but you can call me genie
how does somebody as big as you fit into
this tiny lamp don't worry i'm used to
squeezing myself into titles
can you help us we're in danger
i can't marry her why was your name
nothing what do you mean no was it you
no i've just been doing a lot of
thinking and i just don't think
just hold for a second oh the world's
tempestuous sea
guard us guide us keep us feed us
for we have no help but
i'm thee steve's law sorry
um crisps
nuts
um
a french bread slowly slow down derek
sausage rolls french
bread
[Laughter]
i think you should put it back where you
found it i can't what if a cat gets it
or a magpie i think
put it somewhere safe
why what's he doing well oh no no time
here
[Laughter]
oh that is another guaranteed oscar
seriously
then you just pretend you're getting on
with her
i couldn't do that
of course you could you're an actress
did you hear that
[Applause]
okay i'm sorry i'm hungry this is why i
like to break for lunch about quarter
10.
all her clothes fall off yeah
they uh they fall off onto the ground
and she's scrabbling to get them back on
again but before she can get her
knickers on
i'm walking along the street and i see
this beautiful girl and i think i'd like
to see her naked
and i'm so sorry i don't know what i'm
going to do
i don't know what to do other than leave
the scene and let you talk to a teddy
bear jennifer not with you no she's on
her way
monkey
just tired of people interfering and
telling me how it should be done and be
able to bend over and take up the ass
[Laughter]
just tired of people
telling me how they
think it should be down and we have to
bend over and take out the ass yeah no
disrespect to either of you uh ass
that's not gonna happen you have like a
ratatouille drain pipe so
that's one
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry it was so long i'm sorry
[Music]
it's making me stronger and i can't
stand to leave alone i'm gonna rip one
with his girlfriend pissed no i don't
want one glass did you glug it though do
you know what says here you glugged it
doesn't look like it is
oh pissed i'd had about one glass did
you glug it though you know what it says
then what i'm gonna do
bursting down a
couple of milky coconuts
not quite
what
maybe you've just sit down
maybe if you just sit down
okay um
under strengths
um you've put accounts
yeah
that
isn't that's your job though isn't that
sort of what you do
let's go again
and the weaknesses you've put eczema
yeah on my feet
and the weaknesses
you've put eczema
i'm on the edge all the time
do you remember the question no okay
let's do you let's
we're gonna leave that there
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you're aware that i'm gay
not that
we don't make a song and dance with you
i don't know it doesn't matter
didn't
well no you didn't and you don't make a
song or dance but you don't go oh hello
i didn't know
never have i laughed
out of place ever
until today
[Laughter]
okay
we asked a hundred people will les
dennis ever hang on to a bed our survey
said
[Music]
we asked a hundred people
will les dennis ever hang on to a bird
our survey said
we asked a hundred people do you want to
go out tonight see less dennis in panto
our survey said
[Music]
i mean would this have been funny him
going through customs i have nothing to
declare but my genius oh and this
vibrating tone for pleasure